[Applause]
[Music]
concentrated work split up by holy craps
hey everybody huge surprise they just
confirmed a new Star Wars trilogy is
coming from the director of the last
Jedi so that movie is dropping in a
couple weeks
then Rian Johnson is going to go off and
develop a new trilogy with a bunch of
new characters I'll explain you know
what they've said about it so far they
haven't completely revealed the story
but on top of all that they confirmed
that there's a new live-action Star Wars
TV series that'll be debuting at the end
of 2019 probably some of the best news
that you could have gotten going into
the holidays so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get everything so if you watch my Game
of Thrones videos you just have to
imagine that there will be a point where
we have that kind of Star Wars TV series
airing in addition to all the movie
stuff that's going on which is obviously
going to be awesome and I almost forgot
to say there is a Star Wars ticket
giveaway going on that I'll explain at
the end of the video but the important
details first the Star Wars trilogy that
Brian Johnson is going to develop is
going to be separate from the Skywalker
saga so that's episode 8 episode 9 then
after that obviously there's going to be
another saga trilogy they didn't
completely clarify if the new trilogy
will be the next saga trilogy or if it
will coexist with the next saga trilogy
so episode 9 is the final film in the
current saga after that you have episode
10 11 12 they haven't said much about
that but when they were talking about
Rian Johnson's trilogy they said that it
would be you know exciting new
characters that he's been developing so
it sounds like in the timeline it will
take place after episode 9 but it'll
involve a lot of the other characters
that you see pop up during the saga
films so because they call it a trilogy
it implies that it'll be a continuous
story so it won't be like three separate
spin-off films that are disconnected
it'll be like one story with a bunch of
different characters that'll just focus
on different things in each of the films
a lot of you are asking what about the
obi-wan film that's supposed to come
after episode 9 so right now we've had
the saga films and then we've had the
anthology films in between them like Han
Solo is the next anthology film the one
after that that they said that they're
developing although it's sort of on the
backburner is the obi-wan film they
didn't say when that's gonna drop
there's no firm release
it could come after episode 9 they could
push it even later but it sounds like
Rian Johnson's trilogy will fill the
spaces of the new anthology films so
like you'll have a saga film then you'll
have a Rian Johnson trilogy film then
you'll have another saga film so on and
so forth a lot of people are pointing to
the idea that they said that they would
be doing more stories with Rafe in pose
the characters of the new films like
they're using the current saga to
transition the Star Wars franchise as a
whole between the og Trinity to the new
Trinity which is rape in in Poe
so I'm thinking of the next saga as
being like the continuing Adventures of
those characters we don't know how
they'll be featured in the Rian Johnson
trilogy assuming that that's a
completely separate thing so obviously
there's still a whole bunch of questions
it's almost too soon to speculate on
what the story might be only that in the
timeline it sounds like it'll take place
after the events of episode 9 so
whatever universe shattering
consequences there are as a result of
the war between the first-order kylo Ren
Rey Snoke Luke Skywalker they'll deal
with that in the next saga in this Rian
Johnson trilogy so moving into TV
territory the live-action TV series
doesn't have a name yet they just said
that they're developing it for their
Disney streaming service so it's sort of
like the DC Comics Titans TV show like
that's the new thing like Disney is
developing its own version of Netflix
for just Disney owned content so that's
like Marvel movies that's Disney movies
that's Pixar movies in Star Wars movies
now so they want you to sign up for that
so they're developing a bunch of
original programming and part of that is
this Star Wars live-action series so you
kind of get they're thinking they're
like okay why would people pay money for
a Disney streaming service when they're
already paying money for Netflix will
sweeten the deal by giving them a
live-action Star Wars TV series they've
been asking for for a long time there
are a lot of you that probably remember
after Revenge of the Sith came out they
were developing a live-action TV series
that was gonna take place between
Episode three in Episode four and it was
going to be called Star Wars underworld
it was going to be a dark gritty Star
Wars TV series everybody got really
excited Lucas
hired a bunch of writers they wrote like
50 plus episodes they could they have a
bunch of finished scripts but the
didn't move forward and then they got
bought out by Disney and then it was
just completely shelled so like they
literally wrote all the scripts for 50
plus episodes of a live-action Star Wars
TV series and they're all sitting on a
shelf somewhere so that doesn't mean
that that's what the new TV series is
gonna be they'll probably think of
something different involving new
characters and it'll be set sometime
during the events of the new trilogies
so they haven't really said anything
about the story or what its going to be
but I am assuming for now that like the
Rian Johnson trilogy that's going to be
happening it'll also take place in
present-day it won't be like Star Wars
rebels where it's kind of a prequel but
even though it is the final season of
rebels there will be more animated Star
Wars TV shows that'll probably jump
around in the timeline but I think in
general when it comes to new movies new
TV series they want to focus on new
stuff like obviously they've done all
kinds of Skywalker stuff in this last
saga they bridge the gap with things
like Star Wars rebels and the Clone Wars
I think the big idea now is for them to
push forward with new characters and
that involves just mining stuff from
this current saga so you have the first
order you have the resistance characters
there's a bunch of new characters and
locations that'll be introduced during
the last Jedi I'm assuming the same
thing will happen again during episode 9
like even though it'll be the end of the
trilogy
you'll still run into a bunch of new
people like think about it this way we
didn't know what a pork was until a
couple months ago when they debuted that
first trailer like what the hell is this
bird thing oh that's a pork and now
they're everywhere so just imagine that
in the next couple of years you'll see a
bunch more new stuff and they'll use
that as the basis for the new TV series
in the new movies but let me know what
you think about all this and which
characters do you want them to focus the
Rian Johnson trilogy on and I'm really
curious to see what that TV series looks
like because we have Star Trek discovery
that CBS developed for its streaming
service people had a whole bunch of
complaints about that because there's a
paywall
but I have a feeling that Disney will
have an easier time getting people to
sign up for its service because people
are already watching all kinds of Marvel
Star Wars Pixar Disney stuff so all of
that right now
is on Netflix all Disney has to do is
take it off of Netflix and put it on its
own platform and I think we can assume
that most families are gonna fork over
the
five dollars a month or whatever it's
going to cost it's a lot harder for
people like CBS where it's like you want
Star Trek but you don't want all the
other crap that CBS produces so it's a
lot harder to justify paying that six
dollars a month or whatever it is just
to get Star Trek but they did not
announce a release date for the Ryan
Johnson movies they did say the TV
series is expected to drop sometime at
the end of 2019 because that's when the
Disney streaming service will debut so
just leave all your requests for Star
Wars bonus videos in the comments below
there'll be a lot more last Jedi stuff
happening in the next couple of weeks
because we're getting closer so there is
a new round of that ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video congratulations to the winner from
last video the Deadpool video for wad
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
to watch the new holiday Deadpool teaser
and you can click here for that brand
new Star Wars trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you